West Thursday seventh of may 2015 I
market ask with the reactant returning
officer at the election do hereby give
notice that the number of bonus recorded
for each candidate at federal action it
is follows pre-screen the Conservative
Party candidate 19,000 744 Julianne
healing Labour Party 18,500 three Bob
forcefield UK Independence Party you
hear 7428 Andrew Martin Liberal
Democrats 1947 angie smith independent
321 junk metal vickers trade unionist
and socialist coalition 209 the number
of
as follows wonderful official mark wrong
voting for more candidates and voters n
tackle 234 writing walmart by which the
vertical be identified six being good
marked or polaroid room certainty 156
total of forty-eight thousand seven
hundred and eighty-nine chris
pre-finished incredible waves so close
between conservatives and labour this
campaign as far as I've seen let's be
about the last five years of a
Conservative government's the recovery
recovery we've been seeing it's also as
the campaign's the local campaigns that
we be running we need change important
and this I think is the start I like to
thank the returning officer I like to
thank the staff it's getting a local
night two pounds and when people say
your vote doesn't count here are modern
West every single time every single vote
counts
and I would like to I'd certainly like
to thank all the candidates who have
made this campaign in this election what
it's happy which is a fantastic
demonstration of democracy it's been
absolutely wonderful thank you very much